- [Narrator] So we are given
these two complex numbers
and we want to know
what W sub one divided by W sub two is.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So the form that they've written this in
it actually makes it
pretty straightforward
to spot the modulus
and the argument of each
of these complex numbers.
The modulus of W sub one
we can see out here is equal to eight.
And the argument
of W sub one
we can see
is four Pi over three
if we're thinking in terms of radians.
So four Pi over three
radians, and then similarly
for W sub two
its modulus
is equal to
two
and its argument
is equal to
seven Pi over six.
Seven
Pi
over six.
Now, in many videos
we have talked about when you multiply
one complex number by another
you're essentially transforming it.
So you are going to
scale the modulus of one
by the modulus of the other.
And you're going to
rotate the argument of one
by the argument of the
other, I guess you could say
you're going to add the angles.
So another way to think about it is
if you have the modulus of W
sub one divided by W sub two.
Well then you're just going
to divide these moduli here.
So this is just going to be eight over two
which is equal to four.
And then the argument
of
W
sub one
over W sub two.
This is, you could imagine
you're starting at W sub one
and then you are going
to rotate it clockwise
by W sub two's argument.
And so this is going to be four Pi
over three
minus
seven Pi
over six.
And let's see what this is going to be.
If we have a common
denominator four Pi over three
is the same thing as eight Pi over six
minus seven Pi
over six
which is going to be equal to Pi over six.
And so we could write this,
the
quotient
W one divided by W two
is going to be equal to
if we wanted to write it in this form
its modulus is equal to four.
It's going to be four times
cosine
of Pi over six
plus
i
times sine
of Pi
over six.
Now cosine of Pi over
six, we can figure out
Pi over six is the same
thing as a 30 degree angle.
And so the cosine of that
is square root of three over two
square root three over two.
And the sine of Pi over six
we know from our 30, 60, 90 triangles
is going to be one half.
So this is one half.
And so if you distribute this four
this is going to be equal to
four times square root of three over two
is two square roots of three
and then four times one half is two.
So plus
two
i
and we are done.